and it feels like there's been an awful
lot of Boris Johnson uh in the news
recently as that shows but I really do
want to concentrate on the economy uh
this evening let's start with the
government shall we because a few
moments ago I spoke to the transport
secretary Mark Harper
we were expecting inflation to fall but
it's now stayed at 8.7 are you still
confident that you're going to meet your
target to have inflation by the end of
the year I think the forecast that that
there are out there from the various
forecasts and still say that inflation
is going to fall to that level by the
end of the year clearly it's taking a
bit longer but what that actually says
to me is that we've got to remain
focused on halving inflation and
actually what the government's got to do
the bank of England has the primary
responsibility for reducing inflation
with with its monetary policy what the
government's got to do for the decisions
we take to make sure we help the bank of
England achieve that objective we won't
help anybody if we take steps that cause
inflation to rise so that's why we've
had some what kind of steps would cause
inflation to rise well it's why for
example we've had to make very difficult
decisions which you and I have discussed
before on your your programs about
public sector pay for example it's why
the government has had to make fair and
reasonable offers to people but but have
had to make ones lower than inflation
because if we'd made inflation busting
pay Rises that would have the
forecasters have suggested that would
make things worse we've got to make sure
we keep the public finances under
control so that means making
decisions about how you prioritize
spending so I think if the government
does what it it has control of and works
with the bank of England that's how you
give the banking the ability to drive
down inflation and meet the government's
objectives of halving it by the end of
the year are you really keeping
government spending down borrowing down
I thought debt was now 100 of GDP well
we're controlling public spending
we've made a lot of difficult decisions
you know I set out some borrowings again
last month I made set out some difficult
choices in in my area of Transport
budgets earlier this year that's why
we're making I've been on your program a
lot talking about the tough choices
we've had to make on public sector pay
so I think the government is making
those decisions but it's necessary to
get inflation under control that's
actually the most important thing we can
do if we let if we don't do those things
we slow down the fall in inflation and
that doesn't help anybody and interest
rates I guess it's inevitable they're
going to go up right well I'm not going
to speculate on them that's you know
we've only got to wait until tomorrow
those are decisions for the bank of
England no one welcomes a rising
interest rates and I don't underestimate
how tough it is for people it's one of
the reasons why over the last year the
government's provided
three thousand three hundred pounds on
average of help for every family a lot
of that obviously is the help with
energy bills obviously as energy bills
come down that help won't be as
necessary so we don't underestimate the
difficulty for people we're not
pretending this is easy but getting
inflation down is the thing that will
help people the most I guess
you know you talk about energy but Bill
said
a mortgages I think that's kind of the
point right you know you have this huge
intervention to help people with their
energy bills when they when they were
going up
through no fault of anybody's and people
having to swallow these huge bills
people on mortgage rates on variable
rates or common with their fixed terms
deals I think we can have a quick look
to sort of show how high they're due to
go and how painful that could
potentially be up to so just the last
few days you can see going back back up
to the average interest about six
percent 5.72 percent
some people will be saying this is
disproportionately impacting a smaller
number of people why aren't you stepping
in specifically to help them well look I
think the chancellor was asked this
question specifically yesterday when he
was in the House of Commons and he made
the position very clear if you pump uh
more debt into the economy you actually
slow down the Fallen inflation and you
actually make things worse so the best
thing you can do is work with the bank
of England help them drive down
inflation the forecasts that are out
there from independent forecasters so
not not the government's forecast still
say that inflation will be significantly
reduced by the end of the year that is
the best way we can help people
including homeowners who are facing
higher mortgage rates the government's
not pretending it's going to be easy for
anyone but unless you get that inflation
under control actually you're not
helping anyone at all now I just want to
talk about this in like really simple
sort of language right I'm not an
economist so I'm just trying to kind of
get to the bottom of what going on in
the simplest of ways to help people like
me who are trying to get their head
around all this right so we need
inflation to come down and the way we're
trying to do this is to make borrowing
more expensive and as you say to make
sure wages aren't going up too quickly
so in other words is the aim to make
people feel poorer so they stop spending
so much money
uh well it's it's to slow down the
economy by stopping people a little bit
right to reduce spending
um and then that helps Bear Down on
inflation and then on keeping so that is
kind of that that is correct keeping
discipline on public sector pay which is
the thing the government control is
partly for the direct effect of
controlling public sector pay but also
to make sure that you then don't
um drive up pay elsewhere in the economy
because keeping pay under control is
important and that's difficult as well
you know people you've had this
conversation about New York if you do
inflation busting pay Rises it it
doesn't help so I'm just going back to
well I'm trying to work out right so in
a way it's going to be painful but
that's kind of the point
I said look no one thinks this is is
easy for people but if you if you don't
get inflation under control the worst
thing is not getting inflation under
control as the chancellor may clear so I
think have to stick with which is called
Square on uh you know we have seen it
come down but it's not coming down as
fast as we would like so we've got to
stick with it uh that's the best tax cut
you can deliver people is to get
inflation under control but I think
we're pretending it's going to be
straightforward let's have a look at the
international comparison here because we
had months of people saying look the
target is to get inflation down that's
what this government's all about it's
you made it one of your five pedgers
you've said judges on this right and if
you compare the inflation rates in the
UK the US and the Eurozone I just want
to have a look here UK inflation 8.7 the
US four percent Eurozone 6.1 percent
I mean it looks a bit like a UK problem
well no if you if you listen to the ons
when they were setting out the inflation
figures I listened to them carefully one
of the points they made you've got to be
careful with the comparisons
internationally because of the way we've
chosen to support people with Energy
prices and that actually does make a
difference in the international
it does make a difference in the
international comparisons the ons said
that themselves look inflation's been
high uh globally interest rates are
going out come on around it except I'm
not trying to I'm not trying to have a
go in this interview I'm trying to get
to the bottom and stuff right I'm trying
to have a grown-up conversation about
the interest rates if there is a UK
specific problem is it not better to say
this is why this is what we're going to
do about it
there's a problem in order to fix it
interest rates have been high anywhere
we've been very clear that inflation is
in sticky in terms of coming down part
of the reason you know when we were
having these all the conversations we've
had this year about why a public sector
in the UK
because one of the reasons we made the
point about public sector pay was to
make sure we get pay under control
because one of the things we were
concerned about was not doing that
why is it sticky in the UK why is that
well if you listen to theorists there's
lots of factors that drive inflation
some of it's International and we we're
suffering from some of those as well
Energy prices
some of it's on the effect that pay has
in the economy one of the other things
is you'll know post pandemic we saw a
lot of people leave the labor market uh
which means you've got a very tight
labor market which pushes up pay one of
the things the government is doing
things that we can control through the
department of work and pensions is
looking at helping people who fell out
of the labor market to get back into the
labor market which helps then so it's
high wage under control you
you think it is higher wages well that's
part of the problem if you look at the
things that are driving at prices that's
why people take a paper that's why no
that's not what the government's saying
we're saying we want to get more people
into the labor market that's what we're
doing through job centers looking at
skills getting more people into the
labor market and that's how you enable
the economy to continue growing but
keeping pay under control
um do you have confidence in the
government of the bank of England
yes the government look the governor of
the banking has a difficult job to do
the job of the government and the
chancellor is to work with the governor
and the monetary policy committee to
support them to get inflation under
control they're doing an important job
uh it's a tough job
um they're independent for a reason uh
they have to make these tough decisions
um but the government's working very
closely and has confidence in the bank
yes why why do you have confidence in
the government the bank of England
uh because I think he is doing that he's
making the tough decisions with the
monetary policy committee that are
necessary it's never popular to put up
interest rates I think the bank has a
job they were too slow right that's a
criticism isn't it
some people make that criticism yes and
there was a decision to make at the
beginning about whether inflation was
transit or not you may remember Rishi
sunak made it clear when he was
Chancellor that he thought inflation was
a problem actually he saw that early on
one of the reasons why one of the
reasons why I backed him to be prime
minister because I think he uh he knows
his stuff when it comes to economics
that's why he wants to support the bank
in driving down inflation because he
knows that it's only when we get
inflation under control that we'll be at
a then lower interest rates and get the
economy motoring and grow it okay uh
we'll have to see what happens but
certainly you know difficult as you
ignore yourself a difficult a few months
if not longer a few years potentially
ahead for the UK economy
um I wanted to talk to you about Ukraine
uh if I may as well um you were
answering more support for Ukraine yes
so the Prime Minister as you know
there's the Ukraine recovery conference
today and tomorrow which the government
is hosting with the government of
Ukraine which is taking place in London
and the Prime Minister this morning set
out further support for Ukraine in terms
of uh guarantees for loans also very
importantly
um an insurance framework or risk
framework to enable prior the private
sector to have confidence to invest and
president zielinski spoke virtually at
the conference this morning I spoke at
one of the sessions following the Deputy
Prime Minister of Ukraine
um for some of their reconstruction
efforts so the government remains
focused not just on helping with
supplying weapons and other support but
also helping with the reconstruction of
Ukraine and helping them keep their
economy going which I think is
incredibly important okay
okay thank you